welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and this is the
channel where we break down all the
latest movies and new game releases TV
shows and comic books 21 bridges is
making its way through cinemas worldwide
and the film packs a lot of twists and
turns that will keep you guessing during
its one hour 40 minute runtime
throughout this video I'm gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the film it's ending and
my general thoughts on the movie there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to watch the film
yet and don't want to know what happens
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into a breakdown of 21
bridges okay so personally I think the
movie should be called 21 dead cops
because down this film does not hold
back on the body count at all from the
off the film operates in moral shades of
grey and every character in the movie
has a darker side to them and a
relatability that makes the characters
far more realistic and grounded than in
the typical crime thriller that we
normally get this is exemplified by our
protagonist and Ray Davis who is played
masterfully by Chadwick Boseman
Davis pretty much inherited the role of
a policeman from his father who was
killed in the line of duty after trying
to apprehend three criminals that turn
on him during the arrest
this is vastly shaped Davis and
throughout his career he is operated
with a shoot first ask questions later
mentality in order to not make the same
mistakes as his dad this has brought him
into an internal affairs investigation
and it's also this reputation as a gun
with a badge that means he becomes a key
player in the plot ahead the movie
really kicks off during a botched
robbery with characters Michael and Ray
both of whom have been hired to steal
their ikki lows of coke for a drug
dealer upon arriving at the scene and
carrying out the act they are shocked to
instead find 300 kilos of the narcotic
and things quickly turned south when
policemen arrive at the location Michael
and Ray both possess military training
and due to the former's skills he is
able to kill a policeman as well as the
backup that arrives at the scene with
several officers dead a massive manhunt
begins for them with Davis or during the
shutdown of all bridges and tunnels
in the metropolis of Manhattan as they
attempt to close the net on the - it's a
brilliant premise and now the film
itself takes place across multiple areas
for some reasons I had flashes of a die
hard movie in both its tone and
atmosphere there's an undercurrent
throughout that we aren't getting the
full picture and as the movie progresses
it becomes clear that things aren't as
they seem I'm just gonna spoil the
ending right now because I think this
knowledge is needed to add the context
for the film and why things happen the
way that they do so it turns out the
police officers are precinct 85 are part
of a drug movement within the city and
for a cut of the profits they transport
narcotics throughout the area the
policeman that arrived at the scene
early on were partaking in the movement
of the 300 kilos an a and Michael and
rage has happened to be in the wrong
place at the wrong time
captain McKenna of the 85 played by JK
Simmons just once the entire mess
cleaned up before the operation is
unearthed and luckily for him Davis who
tends to kill without questions is at
the scene and thus he tasks him with
bringing in the two so it seems like
it's all gonna be okay right
well Davis has kind of had a change of
heart and throughout the film we watch
as he sort of rights the wrongs of his
past trying to get to the truth rather
than the target Davis is teamed up with
Frankie burns played by Sienna Miller
who is really having a career revival at
the moment and together they track down
the two and say attempt to make their
escape the movie beautifully portrays
both sides of the struggle with Michael
and Ray desperately trying to get off
the island and away from everything it
looks like they may have a shot - upon
reaching a man known as Eddie who is a
cleaner that can provide them with new
identities and launder their money just
as things look like they're working out
for the two though police show up at a
DS and shoot him through the door
without even giving warning daddy tells
Michael of two thumb drives that he
keeps on his computer and the codes to
access them and the thief manages to
grab them before making his escape with
Ray the police finally get through and
shoot Eddie
and we later learn that Frankie tipped
them off when Davis checks their phone
pretending to not have any battery on
his to make a call it's a real light
other out of sheer bad luck ray and
Michael went to the person that was also
laundering the police's money and this
is kind of what helped the close the
circle in on them this is why addy
threatens the police before they shoot
at him as he knows he has connections in
the force that are supposed to
heck Tim Davis and Frankie managed to
find ray and Michael and Davis manages
to kill the former almost stopping
Michael who takes Frankie hostage and
escapes during their exchange Michael
informs Davis of the two thumb drives
and discusses the strange turn of events
that have caused the night to go haywire
this tips Davis off slightly to the
bigger picture and he decides that he
needs to bring him in rather than take
him down as he has done in the past with
suspects
Michael breaks into a random hotels
guest room and after holding them at
gunpoint gets the password to their
laptop which he uses to scan the thumb
drives with here he discovers that the
cleaner was keeping tabs on all of the
outgoings and incomings in every aspect
of the drug trade in the city and this
includes a list of police badge numbers
from the 85 as well as the amounts of
money that they have earned from being
in on the distribution process Michael
changes his appearance but the long arm
of the law still manages to track him
down and after an awesome chase scene
Davis comes face-to-face or rather gun
to gun with the character on the subway
here Michael tells him about the content
of the flash drives but just as he's
about to surrender Frankie arrives and
shoots him I don't know where she came
from though as she clearly didn't get on
the train like you could see the front
and the end of it and Yoshi clearly
wasn't on as it left look never mind
it's a movie
Frankie blames her poor judgment on the
fact that she couldn't see him and let's
face it this guy is responsible for the
death of many of her co-workers Davis
checks her phone like I said earlier and
later on in the movie there's lip
service paid to the fact that he also
checked the drives and made the info on
them public before going to confront
McKenna at his house this is where we
learned that the police arrived at the
drop-off that Rae and Michael were
robbing and that this entire movie was
basically McKenna trying to cover up the
conspiracy while it's also avenging the
death of his friends he says that the
police are pretty much protecting a city
that hates them and that due to the pay
that they get it's difficult to keep
roofs over their family's heads without
making a bit on the side
he asks Davis to look the other way
saying that if he doesn't he will always
be looking over his shoulder
due to ratting out fellow officers but
Davis refuses saying that he'd rather
look the devil in the eye and just as it
looks like he's about to take McKenna in
his coworkers arrive and start shooting
have the character this is a brilliant
shootout boat yeah there's more dead
cops cuz it's not like this movie had
enough already
and Davis manages to kill McKenna by
shooting him through the wall at his
home before asking him to surrender
which he refuses to Frankie arrives
again out of nowhere like she seems to
just be hanging around outside of places
til it's time to shoot and she holds
Davis at gunpoint he manages to talk her
into surrendering using her daughter as
leverage and police close in on the
house and Davis escorts her outside
before driving back over one of the open
bridges with the snap thumb drive now
whilst this may seem like a slightly
happy ending it's actually not really
that good when you think about it
Davis has pretty much caused a huge PR
nightmare for the police and there's
also the fact that Rae and Michael sold
their cocaine Hall to a drug dealer who
will now be able to flood the market due
to the police no longer being a
roadblock that he needs to give a cut to
over all 21 bridges as I stated earlier
operate in a shade of grey that really
makes it so that at the ending of the
film there are really no winners every
side takes a loss Davis has missed out
spending time again with his severely
ill mother and no doubt the internal
affairs investigation that was brought
off because of how trigger-happy he was
will now have a lot more scrutiny in it
and you really get the feeling that
though Davis quote/unquote did the right
thing it came at a huge cost to me this
is exemplified by one of the film's
final shots in which we see the thumb
drive snapped which symbolizes that the
entire force drug trade and basically
the underworld of New York has been
broken open and is now out into the
world revealing the city's true face
Davis is at a crossing point now which
is cemented in his travelling of the
bridge and he has decided to go in a
direction that takes him away from all
the corruption and the dirty side of the
city that will hopefully lead to him
getting out of it for good it's a somber
note to close on and we cut two credits
ending the film
but what did I think of 21 bridges
overall well though 21 bridges is
getting pretty bad reviews currently
sitting at 46% on Rotten Tomatoes I
really enjoyed the film there are some
loose threads that I would have liked to
have seen resolution - such as the ia
investigation and its absence from his
mother but other than that the film is
really well made it's got a great pace
to it and all of the performances most
notably chadwick boseman and Sienna
Miller provide a gravitas for the work
that makes this feel like one of the
greatest cop dramas that we've seen in
years
the Russo brothers have their names all
over the marketing of this but I'm not
sure exactly how much they actually had
to deal with the work as it feels very
alien to their typical projects let's
not say it's bad either and they have
clearly brought together a tight script
and style that means this is a great
throwing watch I had a lot of fun with
21 bridges and I have to massively
disagree with the critics on this as I
found it really enjoyable if frozen 2 is
too young for you and you want something
to sink your teeth into this weekend
then I definitely recommend that you
check this out and that's why it gets an
8 out of 10 now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on 21 bridges and if
you agree with my review or side more
with the critics comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to check out my breakdown
of this weekend's other big release no
not frozen - the mandalorian episode 3
we go over everything you need to know
about the series and give our thoughts
and what could be happening going
forward so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want something else
to watch after this you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition YT well head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else then that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 2 box on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on 21 bridges in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of
December and the set will be shipped out
from then to ever get surprise so best
of luck to everyone
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]